okay
oh missing a few things
just take care of that
shrek turned 20 today yeah
oh connor i hate you right now
are you a fan of kiss not really it's
just not uh it's not my genre
really that whole sort of
over-the-top arena rock
eh it's not really my thing
so how's the pin looking is that on is
that a line
there we go good good good good
huh so
hope everybody's doing okay today
today was intended to be a relaxing day
i'm so bad
at just chilling my plan was my plan
going into this day was
i had tomorrow's video that i had a
little bit of editing to finish on my
plan was to finish that within like
an hour two at the most in the morning
and to then spend the rest of the day
just chilling like
i i i was i was gonna start in earnest
watching
um castlevania the fourth season
so what ended up happening was i
the edit took me about four hours
uh to get done oh no that's an
exaggeration
three it took about three and then
i got as far as doing a little bit of
reading after which i was going to start
watching
watching castlevania but then um a
packaged uh arrived
and one of the things in
the package was
the test print copy
of my book which mean i had which means
i had to immediately
start flipping through it and
then a ton of stuff
that i've probably been looking at for
months jumped out at me as being wrong
and so immediately as soon as this son
of a gun was in my hand
i had to go to the document and start
fixing things um most of it
like little formatting gaffs things just
not
things accidentally format formatted uh
like centered when they when they
weren't supposed to be
uh the main thing that i really had to
do was um
was trying um and i'm i'm still working
on getting this
sorted out firmly uh was the world map
because here's how it
currently is and frankly it's too dang
small
like especially in the monochrome print
you can't read it so um
i need to i'm still working on this
blowing this up and stretching it across
two pages instead of its current one
where it it just
it it doesn't work
um so yeah
um i've seen a number of um
ats uh blow past me you'll have to
forgive me i don't have the
um the energy to
um scroll back through so feel free to
ask again
um or there's always the super chat
which ensures that
it will be read ah
did you see the trailer for the new ev
dear evan hansen movie
i saw that it exists
i didn't watch it because i like i know
nothing
about it mother okay
i gotta put this on hold because i just
managed to spill
my entire cider so
back in a bit oh my god
this is um
this is infuriating hang on
huh let me put something up
[Music]
um
you know what we're just going to do
that
so move this
that just sets uh sets everything off
very nicely
go ahead and do that stick that right
there
and uh close that for a bit
all right back in a few minutes
uh
you
uh pretty sure i didn't mute the
microphone so you get to hear me just
deal with this i suppose the upside
is at least i wasn't drinking wine
tonight
or anything that would actually stain
the rug
so it could have been worse as far as
these things go
i am uh going to take that as a sign
from the universe to just
not get another drink annoyingly that
was my first one of the evening so it's
not
like um it's not like i can blame
the drink that i'd have all i've had all
of
three sips of on this
at least i hope not i hope i'm not that
much of a lightweight
good grief
okay we're getting there just
another minute or two
okay almost there
hmm
all right i think that'll do it
huh
all right
okay so i me i missed some super chats
let me
catch up on those so that that we're off
to a very auspicious start here
uh first off edward badour you get a
heart
blah blah blah sonic screwdriver blah
the end
very well said and angie
you also get one go buy yourself a drink
on me when you're able to go to bars
happily okay
let's see if we can pick up where we
left off
oh please tell me we're talking about
dreams of fire
sometime tonight i mean to a certain
extent stephen
um good to see you by the way because i
mean i got my i got my
test copy in so um on a day that i
wasn't com planning to completely take
off
um but i was planning to mostly do stuff
for
fun uh i ended up spending combing
through this
because i spotted all of the thing all
the errors that suddenly became
immediately evident
once it was physically in my hand so um
i mean next live stream will actually
basically be the launch party for the
book
um but yeah i mean you can talk about it
if you want just realize most of the
people in the chat
will not have read it and don't yet have
the ability to do so
i got my first covid vaccination that's
great rebecca
i'm getting i'm getting my second shot
end of the month
um congratulations on your first copy of
your book comes out on the day after my
birthday
i'm gonna snap it up uh as a present to
myself oh
well i hope it's worth the wait
can't wait to read the novel thank you i
once left a book in the car
and it was such a hot summer day that
when i came back the glue melt and all
the pages fell out
i'm assuming that's in response to i i
on twitter
i shared this i left a um a jar of
vitamin gummies uh
over the weekend in the back of a heart
hot car and they
congealed into a single vita brick
it's uh yeah
um when they release the cinderella 2021
trailer will you react to it
i'm sorry the what now
huh ah my birthday's at the end of the
month ooh
lots of birthdays coming up uh
i'm gonna get the print edition via jeff
bezos's evil empire
i mean the the thing is for um
individual purchases you kind of have to
it's going to be available through
ingram but that's
not designed for a consumer experience
that
is um that's designed you know for
wholesalers and libraries and and
whatnot
that said i'm working on okay i gotta
huh gotta try to
gotta try and explain this so this this
will be a little bit of inside baseball
uh on try on trying to self-publish oh
first of all john hey
it's good to see you um
uh the novel has a spot picked out on
our bookshelf
uh when we finally put it back together
right next to your other book oh
thank you as the beatles said it's okay
to leave your vitamin gummies in a hot
car
yeah they they were quite wise okay so
i have ended up not intending to
but through realizing a few things
um i have re i have ended up with
way more editions of this book than i
intended
uh because my original plan was just to
have
the uh you know one ebook edition
one print edition with the initial plan
being that the print would have
monochrome
uh illustrations which like is what is
going on
that's what i had done in in the test um
copy that i got um
and the and the um
the ebook would have full color there
were a couple of things i
came to realize though as i was setting
all this up
the first is and i didn't realize this
because i don't use an e-reader
um but it got noted to me by several
people and it's been
reaffirmed by several others since then
that e-readers actually aren't really
good
for illustrations a lot of them don't
handle it well and it
just kind of like it's not great and
so the first thing i did was like okay
so in case people don't want the hassle
of
trying to deal with the illustrations
i'll offer a
edition of the um ebook
without the illustrations same price
because it's not there's like there's no
printing cost so same price either way
just take your pick
but then i realized that meant
that the only way to get
the full color illustrations was through
the ebook
which i have now found out is not a
great experience
with illustrations so
then i did two things
one i realized i have to come up with
some kind of
full color illustrated print edition
um i'll come back to that and if i'm
gonna do
that i might as well also offer
a version without the illustrations for
a lower price
because i had i'd put the um the poll up
twitter facebook youtube community tab
and my patreon
would people actually be interested in
having that as an option and
while the percentages varied every
single place i put that poll the answer
was yes
so i set that up that wasn't too hard
the color illustration turned into a
massive pain in the butt okay so here's
the problem
um here's the problem and here's my
workaround the problem
is that having amazon
because this is all being done through
print on demand through amazon
um which works really well for
self-published authors
but the problem is that
while amazon can do
full color print um
[Music]
it's stupid expensive
um and like not necessarily to me
because since
you know it since i don't have to buy
these in advance it's not actually cost
to me
but i the amount that i would have to
sell it for
would have been absolutely absurd
i it like it was completely unreasonable
so here's what i have found out
and i'm working on getting it all locked
down and it should work
we'll see and that is
that ingram where i'm setting it up so
it can be purchased by bookstores
library schools etc
they could actually do me a full color
hard cover that's the other thing amazon
only print on demand only does paperback
so even the full color at a stupid price
would have been a paperback edition
through ingram i can do hardcover
full color illustrations for for
less significantly less than amazon
would have done
a full color paperback
now the way that this is supposed to
work
fingers crossed is that once
the um once the
hardcover edition has been set
up with ingram i can
then assign amazon as a distributor
which means that amazon won't print
the hardcover but
they will carry it through ingram and
because i'm getting to set it at
ingram's pricing which is far more
reasonable
that means that if everything goes
forward the way it
should there will be the digital edition
selling for 10 bucks there will be
a um you know what i can get prices and
actually tell you what i'm currently
looking at
for this so hang on check something else
okay that
all right that looks good um sorry i had
something else up here let me just check
that
awesome great terrific
cool um so that's the i i
moved over to my browser immediately
pulled up the print preview for the
latest
uh switches that i'd made to the um
uh to the book so
the plan right now ebook which is
definitely releasing on june 1st the
ebook
you know barring um you know people
telling me about
like spelling errors or something the
ebook's locked
so that'll definitely be available june
1st
with or without illustrations and if you
get it with illustrations it'll be
full color assuming your e-reader
displays color
um so that'll be available for 10 bucks
there will be um an edition
of the paperback with no illustrations
except for the world map of the world in
the city map because
those are for reference that'll be 12.99
a paperback um
monochrome illustration uh
edition that should end up being
1999 and then
again assuming that this workaround does
actually work
um then there will be a hard cover
full color illustration
and that um let me get that
pulled up here because i want to be sure
that i'm
that the price in my head is actually
what i landed on um
[Music]
okay and that'll be uh
[Music]
that'll be 49.99 which i know is
expensive
but realize that it's hardcover and also
realize that um
[Music]
it would have been that just as
expensive
um to get
i might bring that down i might bring
that down to 44.
um but it would have been at least that
expensive to get it
um i gotta decide on that to get it done
as a paperback and that would have been
at basically no margin i would have made
nothing on that
and while you know what i make
per sale isn't my top concern
like it's a factor i i would like to
make something
you know i i have i've tried to price
these at what i consider to be
reasonable but you know
i would like to make something back um
edward another heart for you
i'm so far behind on the chat right now
it's ridiculous i decided to start
writing a comic slash graphic novel
somehow my story ended up needing 10
volumes when i mapped out the story arcs
rest in peace my sanity yeah that um
that tracks uh
i can read i can recommend a booktuber
who reads a lot of fantasy and sometimes
accepts indie books for review
um yeah hit me up with that info i did
um get in touch with a number of
booktubers um most of them did not get
back to me
um you know offering them a um
uh i can't think offering them a
digital advance reader copy for review
couple of them got back to me most of
them didn't but you know i'm happy to
send it out to more people
uh that means i can order through my
regular bookstores as soon as i know the
ispn for your book
yes yes if you wish to support your
local bookstore
the um well any of the print
editions but definitely the hardcover uh
full color will be available through
your local bookstore
so there you go uh
oh hey meg nice to see you pop in
um hang on i think i think i'm about to
sneeze
ah there we go lovely i should have
muted the microphone
huh what are your thoughts on the pitch
perfect trilogy i only ever saw the
first one it was
fun it was dumb but it was fun
uh
what was the booktuber vera did the
asexual vid with um
dave uh she's actually changed her name
um
it's now uh kiera the scrivener
is uh is what she goes by now
uh hi meg
uh because untight thank you vaccine
side effects i think i'm far enough from
that first shot that i doubt it's that i
do find a violence sneeze very
sexy meg i can never tell whether or not
you're joking
and i kind of like that um
what is the best way uh to get you her
channel name and
info so you will see it quickly um
either
tweet it at me or email me council of
geeks at gmail
because like if you were to drop it here
i
unless i wrote it down and even if i did
you know
probably get lost in the shuffle uh tara
thank you very much you get a heart i
know it's not normally your genre
but i just caught up with handmaid's
tale and wonder if you've
seen it or have opinions i i haven't
seen it and i don't have opinions
now to be clear um there was a point
when
i probably wouldn't have watched it just
because i didn't want to be depressed
um at this point i'd probably
um be okay to
um to watch it the problem is
i don't have hulu and there aren't
enough things
exclusive to hulu that it's worth it to
me to pay for it
so that's what's going to keep me from
watching it
and i don't torrent so have you ever
gone camping before oh yeah
not in a long time but yeah uh
have you seen any of daniel green's
video
uh he's my go-to booktuber at the moment
no
i am not uh i'm not familiar with daniel
green
um like i i don't know i like i did
uh i did like a skim of
booktubers who um you know looked like
they might
have had interest um it wasn't a deep
dive my
knowledge of the community is
um i mean not that i don't like booktube
i like it quite a bit but i don't read
enough books
so i feel very i feel very inadequate
sorry for asking again i think you
missed my question which version of the
book
would make you earn the most money oh
you're right i did miss that
um
if i leave the pricing where it is the
hard cover is
probably gonna get me the highest um
residual on it um
yeah but that's assuming i don't bring
it back down because i'm looking at that
price again like part of me feels
guilty but like i i don't know
i don't know about knocking it down it's
ah this stuff is frustrating
speaking of pitch perfect ben platt is
clearly recreating the uh how do you do
fellow kids meme
in the dear evan hansen film i'll i
will take your word for that i didn't
watch the trailer
uh nbc is doing annie live what are your
thoughts are you going to watch it
[Laughter]
no no i'm not um
honestly trying to catch net when you've
cut the core trying to catch network
tv um as it
airs is a real big pain in the butt
like i i had to actually sign up for a
free trial of i forget what
something or other just to be able to
watch the oscars that was annoying
well i'll see if i can buy the hardcover
then yeah like the
here's where things are at right now the
the ebook edition
definitely no question will launch
june 1st if i can get everything
sorted the um
the various paperback editions will
launch
for june 1st the open question right now
is whether or not the hardcover
will be available june 1st and right now
i'm inclined to say probably not
that'll probably be available a little
bit later just because
ingram's setup time and things
take a little longer and i got to be
certain it's correct
and then i from what i saw even after i
do that when i
set amazon up as a distributor i've then
got to wait
for the hardcover to show up um
on amazon and i don't have control over
when that happens could take a few days
could take a week
um or two so odds are
that the um
[Music]
that the hardcover will be ready
later in june just because of
how things have have panned out uh this
wasn't necessarily supposed to be
mostly about the book
but um it's
it's turned out that way uh i haven't
had cable in over a decade i have no
regrets oh
yeah i don't regret it either it's just
every now and then
you know something is airing on network
tv it's like ah i do want to see that
and it's a
pain in the butt cut to vero in 30 years
time telling your grandchildren about
the hardships of watching network tv
network tv especially before dvr
oh nightmare
um new cinderella movie's gonna premiere
on amazon prime video are you gonna
watch it
no absolutely not
not when i'm behind on stuff i actually
care about not when i haven't had the
time to watch
the new season of um
uh castlevania or love death and robots
um or i haven't gotten to start infinity
train no i'm not gonna watch a new movie
version of cinderella dear god
no
how do you keep your teeth so poorly
white honestly i don't know i
swear they look whiter on camera than
they actually are
um at least to my eye they do they
always look whiter when i'm
like when i'm editing video um versus
how they look to me and
like just in the mirror um
charles grodin passed away today i saw
that
yeah candidate for the best muppet movie
villain
candidate sure but he can't win because
tim curry
so candidate sure you can nominate him
uh
i have to oh hang on sorry there was
something here
ah oh well whatever missed it what
disney live-action remake do you fear
uh most other than cruella i mean
understand i still don't plan to watch
any of them
um
the fact that they're doing a sequel or
is it a prequel they're doing
they're doing a continuation on the lion
king and it's just
oh dear god
uh does your book account for british
audiences sensibility
no one throws tea into the ocean do they
swear to god if there isn't enough
nodding
um stuff does end up in a lake
i will not say whether or not it's t
nor will i say um whether or not
it was hurled there or ended up um
in unintended circumstances that's the
cliffhanger that i'm going to leave you
on
what are your thoughts on family vlog
channels that's not my
genre i guess
anyone who's going to put their kid on
the internet
like that makes me deeply uncomfortable
i don't watch it
and i just don't think it's a good idea
i just don't and i'm not
like i'm not trying to be accusatory to
anyone who does that sort of thing
obviously i don't watch it but i'm sure
they're perfectly fine families but like
anytime i see
kids who aren't actors who aren't
performers who aren't there to give some
kind of performance in
videos on youtube it
like it just makes me deeply
uncomfortable
i really really hate it
is it bad that i found kermit and fozzie
more believable as siblings than grodden
and diana rigg
god i have not watched
muppets uh the great muppet caper in a
long time that was him right that was
him
uh that was the one what are your
thoughts on uh horton hears a who
the movie it's it's not good
it's garbage it is slightly less
insufferable garbage than
some of the other illumination
adaptations but it's not good
it's not even close to good
uh
lion king 2 was all right i mean i never
saw that original animated version
but i get this out of my lap it's just
this this sucker turned out a hell of a
lot
thicker than i thought it was gonna be
mean this i mean great like it's
it's you know it's larger format it's
it's decent sized print but like this is
this is dang near 400 pages was like i
there is no way that i wrote a 400 page
book
what the hell like that makes no sense
to me even looking at the formatting of
the pages knowing it's not like super
condensed or anything like i did no
i did not no i did not
great muppet caper is on disney plus i
mean i also own it i own it on dvd
i just haven't watched in a long time i
deposit reading your book after the
bombshell dropped about 150 pages in
hahaha you can you can um
oh god what's the word i like i cannot
think tonight
you can commiserate uh with with stephen
partridge
on that one he was one of my beta
readers
and when he
got to that part
he sent me a text string
that was all swears
like positive he's like i can't believe
you [ __ ]
you did that it was just it made me
so happy um
i like i even even after getting that
reaction i'm still
paranoid that like i just happen to work
for him and that other people are gonna
tell me that's
really stupid uh that doesn't work at
all but
you know uh
i'm that that was fun like
i kind of i kind of allude to it
um in so far as like i i did uh
over on the break room i did a video on
twists and my thoughts on plot twists
and without saying what it was in my
book i i did sort of
uh talk about my methodology and my
thoughts on what
the preferable way to tackle twists are
one of the things i didn't bring up um
in that is something that actually i was
thinking about earlier today
there's one more x factor if there's a
twist in the narrative
and that is the the closer to the end
the twist is revealed
the more weight is put on it and
sometimes when a twist doesn't work
all you need to all all the people who
tried would have had to do was
move the twist earlier in the narrative
where not quite as much weight would be
put on it and
it might have held up i mean that's
that's why
uh what caro what car just said that
that bombshell that's why
it's a little less than halfway through
the book
because i don't think
like original original draft
um that reveal came at the end and i
even i even had a back and forth with
theresa hi theresa
who's in the who's in the chat who was
recommending i move it to the back
of the book but i just don't think for
what the reveal
was um
i just don't think it would have held up
to the pressure of being an
end of book reveal um so i moved it
earlier and i'm much more comfortable
with it there
uh and even though like i said i'm still
slightly paranoid about
whether or not uh it works i
i'm less paranoid because
not having having it at the end would
have made the entire book hinge on it a
lot more
since i know that's not the case like
i'm not
nearly as paranoid about it and maybe
that's me wussing out
and not having the faith in my own um
twists in my narrative but it's it's
it's how i became comfortable and
theresa
thank you so much congrats on the book
looks great thank you so much
uh 100 agree i don't like to see
children in videos online because
they're not old enough to consent to
putting their faces online i mean that's
that's
you know that's why my kid uh
has has not appeared on here and like my
kid likes some of the stuff that i talk
about my kid
loves she-ra um
and really love the owl house and i'm
sure like would have had opinions
but first of all she doesn't really have
the um
the specific kind of attention seeking
streak that i do that sort of lends
itself to wanting to appear on video
she's never expressed an interest um
and beyond that like even at the age
that she is i don't know if she really
properly appreciates what it would mean
um to be visibly online and i just
i until she's of an age where i feel
confident that she understands the
ramifications
of doing that i'm she's not
showing up on my channel
uh do you think that a minority actor
should play elphaba
in the wicked movie
i think as much as possible they should
have
um an open casting call as as best they
can because i mean
she's she's got to be painted green no
matter what so there's no reason to
not um cast
someone of uh at least of a um of an
ethnic minority
um of course that's not the only kind of
minority there is but that that's where
my brain went
as well as tim curry there's also chris
cooper
and constantine kermit's evil russian
doppelganger oh
constantine the source of many a meme
that one
you are beautiful as always and i miss
your face
soon that will be remedy i miss you too
jon
and it'll be it'll be really nice oh i
like
some people already know this um
i i did actually get to
go out um
to a burlesque show this past weekend
um and got to see some of my friends
perform i got to see
dixieland delight and katniss everqueer
perform and i went with
with my partner liz and libby lawless
who's another performer as well
uh in the audience and that
that felt so good to go to
and to see um
oh that like i i
i knew i missed it i don't think i
appreciate how much i missed it until i
had it again
um from john you are uh
no you got that one that was ah thank
you for being the
first one told about the wee ones
existence
she wants to meet the the other m and
antivir again ah
i'd i'd be delighted to see your
munchkin again
cutie um i finished castlevania season
four i enjoyed it for the most part
though i think
they had enough material for another
season season three still my favorite
so far season two is my favorite though
that has a bit more to do with the
climax
than necessarily the season as a whole
because like oh my god the assault on
castle dracula and season two
holy crap
oh it's bonkers
new subscriber and follower thank you
thomas welcome aboard
uh the bookworm has arrived hello there
um best cameo in a muppet film
oh huh
that's a good question
like i feel i i feel like my brain is
gonna draw a blank right now and it
would do
me well to like get a list
because the thing is can i be completely
honest
most of the cameos aren't really that
good
you know it's just you either recognize
this person
or you don't and if you don't
you're just like okay they lingered on
that
random one-line character longer than i
would have thought
and
i'm trying to i'm tempted to say
oh okay i was gonna say tina fey except
she appears in multiple scenes so that's
too much for a cameo
so here's what i say
i say josh groban not because i love
josh groban
but because they knew exactly what they
were doing with that cameo
and it was dang hilarious that's why
um they're making a greatest showman too
what are your thoughts
okay you're lying to me i do not
i don't trust you ms wicked wolf you
like to wind me up and i do not trust or
believe you
so i'm googling that right now
uh
oh dear god
oh dear god why
what
oh god damn it
why
it didn't need
a sequel
uh
all right i refuse i refuse to think
about it
that's a horrible idea
that's a really stupid idea season three
of castlevania was my favorite because
it was unrelentingly
bleak i actually think alucard's best
stuff was in that season
see um while i i don't get
completely turned off by unrelentingly
bleak
um it's
rarely my favorite thing so
you were allowed you were allowed to
include big bird by the way oh
yeah that would have been a good pick
too
uh i should
uh probably
check the discord uh which
as a reminder is the one other way to
guarantee that i will see your questions
aside from the super chats because the
discord is a patreon exclusive perk
and if you ask a question there i will
definitely address it
excuse me do you know what the
eurovision song contest
is uh if so how is it seen in the states
i do know what it is i have no idea how
it's seen in the states because i've
never
watched it so i don't even know
if it does air in the states but i know
it exists and i know what it is but i've
never seen it
and depending on your above answers do
you have a favorite eurovision song
winner or otherwise uh no no and no so
not too many questions from the discord
that time and i'm right back
can we please just call it the second
greatest showman
[Laughter]
oh bless your cynical heart meg
i love it um
oh have a good rest cara
sweet dreams uh
i'm in despair about john barrowman ah
yeah i i'm not gonna devote
another video to this
but i i feel
i feel conflicted about
um things like
him you know his upcoming playing stuff
on big finish getting pulled
and the removal from the um
fracture in time attraction
um of his stuff because
again it's just flashing back to james
gunn
for me it's not exactly the same
um because james gunn was um
you know his issue was stuff he had
tweeted a long time ago john barrowman
it was stuff he was actually doing on
the set
um so
but at the same time knowing that
this was um this was just stuff that was
known
like in the and like it was not a secret
there wasn't a cover-up
he would share stories other stars would
share stories
fans who went to conventions and never
heard him talk knew
and only now like and again
to be clear as i dedicated an entire
video to the behavior not okay
it's not but
given how scattered
the determination seems to be in terms
of
um when he stopped because
uh when i did those videos the most
recent um incident that i could find
record of was from 2008.
now since then um i found some stuff
from his co-stars on arrow referring to
it and that dates around 2014.
now that's a little worrying because
first of all it's more recent
second of all it seems to indicate that
at
best he moved the behavior to a
different set
where he had not yet been reprimanded um
and that's not great
but again that's the most recent i can
find
and that like if the if i hadn't found
that if i was still looking at 2008 and
he'd been
clean since then and um no issues
i'd be more likely to side with him in
terms of i don't think it's necessary to
be
removing him from projects but knowing
that
you know i've i've now you know found
you know solid evidence and
i consider a confirmation of stuff more
recent than that
that muddies it a little bit but it
still feels weird
again because it's behavior that was
known
and uh no 2014 i said john or if i said
2018 that's my
mistake uh 2014 was was what i found
dated
uh dated to so
it's
it's really messy and it feels awkward
to me
again because this isn't something that
was a secret and this isn't new behavior
this is stuff that has been known about
for a long time publicly
and now we've decided to get uppity
about it now
uh what would turn
the he john barrowman himself has been
pretty quiet
um which is honestly the best
thing that he could do right now
um so i think
like an apology wouldn't hurt although
you gotta word those really carefully
um but the worst thing he could do
and it would be to publicly get upset
because i i say publicly there because
i do understand why he would feel upset
for the reason that i've said which is
that
people have known about this for a very
long time and
now they're mad at him and now they're
he's losing um
you know work due to it that
does just flatly kind of seem unfair
since it was stuff that was
on the public record and everybody knew
um
but at the same time
um while i understand why he that might
upset him the worst thing he could do
would be to throw a fit
publicly um and i'd probably turn on him
on the issue if he did uh ben ben says i
thought he had apologized what i had
found is he had apologized in 2008
at the time of the last recorded
incident
um when with what happened with bbc
radio 1.
um i hadn't seen that he'd issued any
apologies in light of people now getting
upset about it
if he has i've missed it because i've
kind of had my head down on the book
so i haven't been as tuned in to new
developments as i might have been
otherwise
uh it's almost always behavior that is
known publicly
uh in a long time cosby was known
weinstein was known woody allen was
known
i i'm gonna push back slightly on that
gozer um because woody allen
was definitely known to the public which
is why i
like i haven't watched this stuff for
ages and like
people got refreshed upset about it
it's kind of the same thing with
polanski um
what was weird in those two cases is
that the general public
seemed to have decided that they were
over it which was weird
given what they did
i would actually point out in the case
of cosby and weinstein
those were open secrets within the
industry
i would push back on the idea that it
was known to the
public before things really blew up
now should the public
have been able to pick up on things were
there accusations
yes but like they do have to be reported
on and like that's
that is sort of the thing with john
barrowman that that makes me wonder a
little bit because i think the
fandom has known this about him for a
very long time
um but you know since the behavior is
not
uh appropriate i do wonder
how much of
i've lost my train of thought sorry i
was reading the chat at the same time
and i've lost my train of thought on
that um but yeah i i think
with um with specifically
with um
[Music]
cosby and weinstein the general public
really was not aware
um
and that doesn't make it okay
because the the general public kind of
turning on it
turning on them really felt more than
anything like it
um kickstarted a hard push against those
two which is why things like the metoo
movement is
really important um oh
goodnight meg get a heart even without
super chats because
i know megan person so
sweet dreams meg have a good night i'll
stay up for uh
i'll stay on a little past eight because
we lost a lot of time so i could
mop up spilled cider
there's gonna be a thing one thing two
movie what are your thoughts i refuse to
ponder that long enough to have a
thought
on it i refuse i actively refuse
there's a routine on cosby's 1969 comedy
album about putting spanish fly in
women's drinks
yeah and like i said there are lots of
things that you can go back and look
again and be like the public should have
been better aware
but whether or not you think
um the public the public perception of
these figures
should have included the fact that they
were predatory
the simple fact is is that the general
public didn't know
they they just didn't um
the vast majority of people simply did
not know so you can
cite something from a 1969 comedy
special you know how many people would
have freaking heard that
and remembered it and considered it as
evidence
and not a joke i i don't
i
it's just it gets weird
when there's the issue of yes ms
wicketwolf i saw that you weren't lying
you don't have to keep repeating it
um i
i saw um
you know god i've lost my train of
thought again i'm i'm
like i'm scrambled tonight i think this
is what happens
um uh
i think this is probably what happens on
on a day where i had decided i was gonna
take it easy and my brain has
decided it's not gonna try as hard
um and even when i've started like doing
stuff like it's still not gonna try as
hard
sent you an email with details thank you
cappuccino crafts i appreciate that
um i had to toss the mists of avalon
when i found out about the author
[Music]
my mother has those books and i don't
have the heart to tell her
um about that author
because i mean like that she's passed
away i'm by now i'm pretty sure
and so it's not like my mother's gonna
buy any more of those books
but yeah
that um yeah that was rough
although um my mother did just finish
reading
what the heck is um hold on
uh i gotta
check this name because i'm going to get
it wrong
uh
hang on checking
ah jermaine greer that was it uh my
mother only recently
found out about jermaine grier and what
a
raging turf um
she is and i know that was a big letdown
for her because
jermaine grier was a pretty formidable
um feminist back in the 70s when
you know my mother was very active in
feminist movements she didn't know her
personally or anything but
i know that was really hard for her
to find out about and uh
i just it's tough
it's tough to have to learn about these
things and like
we should we should know where
these ideas and stories
come from and i've said before you can't
separate the artist from the art
but it still hurts sometimes
the only good dr seuss feature film is
the five thousand fingers of dr t
okay
don't know if you saw my earlier post
about uh peter
yarrow another horror i know that name
and i don't know
why i've definitely seen that name
before
i don't know who they are though
i know something that would make you
feel better how do we
know that this oh god and there she goes
quoting
hamilton at me uh it's been difficult
for me too vera
yeah yeah i believe it caroline
erica thank you very much for the super
chat you get a heart
what gives someone a second chance when
they act
in horrible ways does it depend on what
they did and the sincerity of the
apology
if given i think it depends on a number
of things
um i think the first is that
there is not going to be a universal
standard of
forgiveness which is one of the things
that like
certain people just infuriate the hell
out of me
when like with john berryman they came
in saying
you know he apologized get over it first
of all
if his apology
met your level that you need
to feel comfortable with what it was he
did that's great for you
you don't get to dictate whether or not
other people are now comfortable with
him
or whether or not they feel we should
still be talking about it i come back to
that video i did a couple weeks ago
don't tell other people how to feel
so whether you have
chosen to um
forgive someone like john berryman or
any other sort of figure like that
or not has no bearing on whether or not
other people do
they will make their own calls based off
themselves
nobody is obligated to forgive someone
or be comfortable with someone that
still skeeves them out like let's
establish that
right off so the
the question itself i think it does
depend
on what was done
the sincerity of the apology and
honestly
just the sheer passage of time
because to pull an example of someone
who doesn't really get talked about
anymore mel gibson
first got in trouble when he had that
traffic stop
where he was drunk and he called the
um debate of whether i was going to say
this i'm just going to say it
um called the female officer sugar tits
and asked the um the
arresting officers if they were jewish
and going on a rant about jews
now that was quite a while ago
the reason regardless of whether or not
you bought his apology at the time which
i didn't but the reason his career still
hasn't really recovered
isn't because people haven't forgiven
him for that but because he had
more stuff kept happening since then
there was the voicemail that came out
where he was shouting things at his i
think
that it was either his ex-girlfriend or
they were still dating
but he was shouting this horribly racist
stuff
in a voicemail and like it was an
affirmation that he hasn't he didn't
learn
and no matter what he said about trying
to change he didn't
and his career has never really picked
up again since then because
after that basically everyone went
he clearly didn't learn so
i think the
severity of the original offense um
is going to set everybody's own personal
uh factor about it and how and what they
need
um
oh the voicemail sent to his kid oh that
was another one that was a different one
as well yeah there were multiple
voicemails um
anyways the so there's the whatever the
severity of the original
offense is that's an issue but then
how long can they go without
causing new issues because the thing is
time has proven alec baldwin also had
voicemail stuff
with his kid i don't actually i don't
know if mel gibson also had a voicemail
with his kid
they both had voicemail scandals it
would there was a whole bunch of stuff
um anyways
um so
time passing and not reoffending because
if people aren't actually going to
change and if their apology
was insincere
then they're going to slip up again time
has borne that out
repeatedly so
it's why i doing so with trepidation
but i have actually started to watch
the second season of the mandalorian
because while i can't exactly say i'm a
fan of gina carano my biggest hang-up
was rosario dawson
and the accusations against her and her
family
which at this point she herself
specifically was dropped from the
lawsuit
the whole thing might be dead now at
this point but more importantly to me
nothing new has come up since then
and enough time has passed that i feel
like okay
she only appears for a little bit in
this show i
think i can be comfortable giving it a
shot
and it was because not only did you know
specific transphobic things not come up
but
nothing else to me that she said or did
publicly
or that came out about her indicated to
me that
that this was going to reoccur now it
might
and i'm going to be nervous that it will
for probably a long time but
enough time has passed that i'm
comfortable trying to give it a shot
so and again that's gonna vary
um depending on
your own level of comfort with with what
the original offense was
um i feel the same about people who
defend chris brown by saying rihanna
forgave him so let it go already oh god
yeah screw that defense
her forgiving him is between the two of
them
anyone else who looks at chris brown and
says that dude is gross and should not
have a career
they have every right to think that for
the record that dude is gross and should
not have a career
so
did it make you feel better yes miss
wicket wolf a little bit thank you
uh
uh so i think i am probably going to
wrap up
relatively soon
to me the mandalorian felt more like
pilots for future disney plus star wars
content
it all took me out of season two very
jarringly i mean i'm i'm only one
episode in
uh so i'll keep you posted but it's it's
been all right so far um
and like right now i'm prioritizing um
castlevania over that when i have time
which is never i never have time
controversial opinion life of brian is
the worst money python film
you are so very wrong
that's not a controversial opinion
that's just wrong that's
factually wrong sorry
you know how much i love to quote
hamilton are you oh yeah i'm i'm well
aware
i want to turn that dude is gross and
should not have a career into a gift
go ahead meme me
uh by all means have you watched shadow
and bone on netflix it's amazing
i have not uh liz i think she finished
it
um she liked it pretty well um
castlevania season four is my top
priority for when i can get a freaking
second to breathe
um but no i haven't seen it yet
uh apparently disney had put gina
forward for any consideration
i mean that might be a bit of an olive
branch who knows
hey i'm not
i'm not going to dwell on it i'm curious
what is your opinion on shrek
it was
it was really good for the time
it hasn't aged well uh a lot of comedies
especially ones
trying to parody something specific
of the moment a lot of them don't age
very well
um as a film i actually think the second
one's significantly better
uh the first one relies a little more
heavily
on um on just
taking pot shots at disney um second
one's better
but like that first one was
it was a big deal when it happened it
was a game changer in a lot of ways
um remember when i told you about the
controversy surrounding
camilla cabello on twitch uh vaguely
um but like
i don't i think my brain kind of
crumpled up that information toss it
into my mental junk drawer i don't
really recall now
talking about big finish what store do
you think is going to win
the seventh doctor and eighth doctor
pull
um i didn't realize there was a poll
going on
i again i like i'm massively out of the
loop right now
because like i've just i've had my head
down on work mostly the book
so like i'm so not up to date on
so much have you seen rango i have it is
a
gorgeous movie that is not very good
it looks amazing i wish it was a good
movie
it's not like it at all
oh katie thank you so much
huh would you ever consider playing
animal crossing and maybe stream games
on twitch in the future congrats on the
books well i do stream on twitch
currently the only thing i stream is
hearthstone because it's the only thing
that
i can run on my ancient ass laptop
and not have it chug uh
like it's trying to gargle uh
gravel so um
you know i i i don't
i i i don't have a lot of options for
what i can do but you i am on twitch
twitch.tv council of geeks um i'll be
streaming tomorrow
actually um animal crossing
it's not my kind of game plus i don't
have a switch
um so i don't really have the means to
stream that one
um even if i if i got a better rig at
home
so like i i do i want to stream more and
a greater variety of stuff
once i get a better computer which
i really need um
but yeah uh
we'll we'll see like i've got i've got a
few things that like i definitely want
to do but
we'll we'll see what's worse big bang
theory or glee
to my tastes big bang theory in terms of
um just being kind of gross uh probably
glee
like the more i look into glee
ah i'm sorry it's
it's racist it's fat phobic
it's it's gross
the show's gross
uh let me see here
got some more super chats woo those came
in uh
gonna head off to bed a good night good
night ben uh
edward thank you again i'm very
reluctant about being excited for
torchwood series 7 by big finish with
everything going on
involving you know who don't know if
i'll buy it now which is a shame series
5 and 6 were great
yeah i haven't listened to the big
finish um
torchwood stuff so i don't know how good
it is but i mean big finish does good
work
um so i'm not surprised that it was good
uh
melody thank you so much
did you see cbs uh did you see how cbs's
clarice managed to address trans issues
and silence the lambs by
turning directly into problematic issues
love your channel
i actually haven't been following what's
going on with clarice i forgot that it
would have started airing by now
um it
um i so i don't know what they've been
doing or how they've been tackling
the those kinds of issues um
so unfortunately i can't give an opinion
now i'm curious
i was gonna say i try and look it up but
that might not do it justice sometimes
these things don't translate to a
synopsis
but glee has not aged well i'm sorry
glee was not okay at the time
the point at which i decided i was never
going to watch glee and it was still
airing at the time
this was like second season of it going
i think um was when i found out there
was an episode called the asian
f about the asian american student
getting and
getting a b
that wasn't okay even at the time
forget aged poorly that's
[ __ ]
just because like it 100 wouldn't fly
today
didn't make it okay at the time elise
thank you so much just celebrating your
author copy oh
i know how it feels to see your book
maybe for the first time in your hands
i'm happy for you
thank you so much like and this um
this isn't this isn't my first rodeo
because like i
i remember having very similar feelings
when when i
finally held skirting gender in my hand
but like
this one's a bit different because this
this
has been so long in the making
it's frankly embarrassing
oh god that cover looks good though
i love i love the cover heart so damn
much
uh thoughts on the mr creosote sketch
and meaning of life i skip it
even as a kid i just thought it was
disgusting and i would skip it
i wish nuhu episode titles uh
sounded as cool as classic who titles
horror fang rock sounds much cooler than
time heist
what do you think i mean some of them
there there are some cool sounding ones
uh from nowadays he didn't get a b he
got an a minor in s
oh yeah even better i don't know if you
think that's a defense it's not
uh but um
anyways are you gonna
re-rank every doctor who series after
you finish individually ranking the
episodes from each series
um possibly uh
so um somebody had asked earlier uh and
i didn't address it whether or not i was
going to continue the take two doctor
who reviews
into whittaker's run
the answer is yes
but there's going to be a pause
so i i need
i need to not do two videos a week for
at least a little while
so um after
i get out the top 10
uh 12th doctor stories
uh top 10 12 doctor episodes once that's
out
i'm going to take a break for at least a
month
i will definitely do series 11.
uh for take two doctor who review
because it's been long enough
i'm debating jumping right into series
12
or whether i'm gonna wait until next
year because that one
still feels fresh like fresh to the
point
of i'm not sure i'm going to have
anything new to say
but series 11 i feel like enough time
has passed that that one's worth doing
um and yes i will i
i will probably do a re-rank
of the series
uh probably after series 13
um especially if series 13 does end up
being
jodie whittaker's final series so
but i i'm not sure yet i'll definitely
do it at some point just like i'll i'll
re-rank the doctors once
she ends her her time excuse me
uh sharon thank you so much
just a comment love your channel i often
send friends and family links to your
videos
because you do such a great job
explaining complex issues oh
thank you i really appreciate that
oh dear it took me seven years to finish
my first book i've used the story as a
tabletop rpg campaign at first because i
didn't know if i could do it
seven years is a decent amount of time
um however
19
19 years
this has been in my head
and now it's in my hand
oh that's still insane oh that is
crazy
uh so
i am gonna i am gonna wrap it up
uh would you make buffy videos i i mean
i have in the past
i don't think buffy's something i'm
gonna tackle again anytime soon i'm not
gonna rule it out
uh it's not impossible
but um no no plans certainly anytime
soon
silent chariot you get a heart
critical hit that's adorable love that
okay i'm gonna wrap it up um i'll be
streaming on the twitch stream tomorrow
about midday eastern time-ish
um a little bit before i forget what i
think it's 10 30
i think it's 10 30 a.m eastern so when i
do that
um but
we'll figure it out that's what it is
for right now
thank you for tuning in thank you for
the
support thank you for the super chats
thank you for listening
just thank you please remember
that you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved you are the council
i am just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
my cavity